take me into one of like kind of the
gnarlier scenarios that you had dealing
with like a human corpse
yeah so the easily easily the only one
that's ever really bothered me the one
that really kept me up was uh
a guy unfortunately took his life in his
basement
with his family upstairs he had two kids
you know teenage uh children and his
wife were there okay and they didn't
leave
they
so the whole time that we were there
working
they stayed so we are carrying stuff in
the room in the basement
they were upstairs yeah and uh but no
you know and normally they they would
always move out
right you know until everything's
completed and put back together in this
case they they did not want to leave so
you roll up to the place
and who are you with is it just you do
you have a little buddy with you this
one was just me um so i'll generally
just go for
like i'll check it out and if i need
labor i'll call for it okay um but i i
generally don't ever ask anyone to do
these gnarly ones with me damn you're
just doing satan's minion baby out there
yeah
you know i'll have people but like i i
never want i never like to ask other
people to do this kind of stuff because
it can really kind of weigh on you okay
so okay right no i can only fathom that
and we'll get we'll get into that a
little bit but so you get to this one
locale and what's going on so like i
said and generally i'm dealing either
with the police or the coroners
um
this is the only situation where i've
like met a family member at a
okay like a suicide particularly um
sometimes if someone's died of natural
causes you know i'll meet a son or a
daughter or a wife or something like
that
but this one i knock on the door and
this lady answers it answers the door
and she was the homeowner so they were
still there like he's killed himself
yesterday and they're all still in the
house
um
and so you know i'm down working in the
basement and i'm carrying up boxes and
bags of you know contaminated stuff
past them
wow so you're just bringing up like
basically stuff that has like human
matter on it yeah like you know oh it's
horrendous so it's like you're like
and so a lot of your head just kind of
goes wherever
yeah does your head go in one piece or
does it go in a bunch of pieces no and
it depends on the type of gun or the
caliber but typically it's just gonna
you know if you shot yourself with like
a hollow point
you'll like blow a hole out of the back
of your head but if it's a if it's like
just a normal handgun or something it's
actually a pretty clean hole normally oh
wow but um yeah it's this was yeah so at
the end every day i had to tell you know
she's asking me questions and
and it's just like i you know you're
looking at her in the eye and saying
it's like oh we're gonna be
finishing taking your husband out
tomorrow you know it's
crazy and did they come down and want to
do any prayers or did they want to like
spend any time pray was there
was it
did they like the husband you know it
didn't seem like they had a good
connection with the who i was really
trying not to talk to him oh you were
yeah it was that that really bothered me
yeah oh i can only fathom man i mean
that's a man
yeah i'm just trying to yeah i guess we
don't know all the circumstance but if a
man yet took his life as families right
there i can only imagine this how
and then i just wonder if they're
looking at you like you're helpful or
like
who knows i have no idea yeah but that
man i still think about that one that
one was
tough
yeah and did the kids try to communicate
with you or anything there was no no i
mean they were obviously grieving but i
mean it was it was wild that they
wouldn't go to a hotel or stay with
family or something yeah at least hit a
damn fair field in in suites or a days
inn
um
you know and i love hampton and actually
but yeah i can't imagine if that
happened then i wouldn't want some space
or
maybe you want to be as close as you
know i don't know i don't know but that
was a unique circumstance
one and only time and hopefully the last
time that ever happened because it
really made it it really added what like
another yeah
yeah you know because you like i said
you get really desensitized to it and
and you know it's just like you're just
cleaning up a mess you know but when
they're there it's like i'm cleaning up
dad right yeah
right right like our allen or whatever
they got yeah yeah
yeah harold or something yeah yeah it's
more i i can't imagine that
gosh i'd almost feel
bad in a way yeah yeah it really gave me
the heebie-jeebies
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one